[Musique]
trois ans déjà que lesdits manning qaîda
fait des pieds et des mains pour
retrouver sa fille et ses petits enfants
partis en syrie avec une islamiste
radicaliser elle mène une croisade pour
convaincre les autorités françaises de
ramener sa famille au pays en sécurité
en novembre 2014 plus de nouvelles de
notre fille sur skype et donc et sahin
novembre la maman allemand nous apprend
que l'histoire est vraie en syrie donc
là ça a été
voilà le début du cauchemar je dirais
j'ai toujours cru qu'un jour je me
marierai ma fille là l'inquiétude de
l'idi a fortement augmenté ces derniers
mois avec la progression des forces de
la coalition internationale contre des
ch
et puis il y a quelques semaines la
terrible nouvelle
lui y est parvenu ce qu'on redoutait est
arrivé c'est à dire qu'on a appris le
décès de julie on appris le décès de
julie par l'intermédiaire d'une maman
pièce fille là bas tu connais pas
exactement les circonstances de son
décès mais la jeune grand-mère apprenait
aussi que les trois enfants de julie
avait été localisé dans un camps du
nord-est de la syrie
quand sans supervision médicale où les
conditions de vie sont très dures le
plus jeune des trois qui a moins de deux
ans a été blessé par des éclats d'obus
au visage et à la jambe
ce militant des droits de la personne
revient du camp syrien al sol où il a pu
voir les trois petits de lydie manning
qaîda les enfants sont malades ils ont
besoin d'un suivi médical je vais vous
donner un exemple le petit fils de lady
qu'il ya un an a été blessé dans le
passé par des éclats d'obus et tous les
enfants que j'ai vu ce sont des enfants
qui ont été traumatisés quelque part ils
ont grandi dans la guerre et notamment
la dernière année pour a été terrible
ils ont fui d'endroit en endroit sous
les bombardements et on voit une réponse
humanitaire très très faibles qui fait
on
et le résultat c'est qu'il ya eu
beaucoup d'enfants qui sont décédés
faveur des combats mais qui sont décédés
après même être arrivé au camp ou
pendant le transport jusqu'aux camps
c'est précisément à cause de l'urgence
humanitaire que la france a envoyé ses
soldats en syrie une opération menée
dans le plus grand secret pour sauver
les enfants les plus mal en point dans
les trois petits-enfants de lydie et
deux autres fillettes
pourtant le gouvernement avait déjà
affirmé que les djihadistes français et
leurs familles n'allait pas être
secourus il peut y avoir la situation
des orphelins
sauf que c'est une vraie difficulté nous
sommes dans un pays la syrie avec une
certaine désorganisation les enfants
sont pas sous l'autorité du gouvernement
français et soldats français et puis ne
m'appartient pas de dire telle ou telle
enfants il est français je vais aller le
chercher
ça n'est juste pas possible il y aurait
une soixantaine d'enfants d'origine
française toujours détenus dans les
camps en syrie le gouvernement veut
procéder au cas par cas pour déterminer
s'il valait ramener ou pas ce qui est
considéré comme une insulte par les
représentants de ces familles emmanuel
macron ne peut pas dire je rapatrie
celui là mais pas celui là
alors toi tu auras la tuberculose et le
choléra y tout mourad encore mais toi
non ça n'est pas possible maintenant que
ses enfants sont répartis et tous vont
l'être
ils doivent l'être
mais ce n'est pas l'avis de la majorité
en france des sondages récents
démontrent que sept français sur dix
souhaitent que les enfants de djihadiste
français restent en irak et en syrie
bah les enfants vont pas revenir tout
seul et vous revenez va revenir avec les
parents s'ils sont radicalisées tout ça
moi je gérais un petit peu peur
peut-être contre alors on va pas les
mettre en prison
donc c'est encore l'état c'est nos
impôts etc
non donc il reste la syrie cet aveu 1
cet avocat représente une bonne dizaine
de familles françaises qui réclame aussi
le retour de leurs proches
les sondages guide aujourd'hui les
décisions qui devraient être des
décisions étatiques dire qu'on est à un
niveau de responsabilité où on doit
prendre des décisions qui sont graves
qui sont lourdes et qui vont pas
nécessairement dans le sillage de
l'opinion publique bonsoir patrick
manning est là merci votre présence est
l'isi manning qaîda a été invité sur de
nombreux plateaux de télé au cours des
dernières années
son message sur l'innocence des enfants
prises au piège dans les combats en
syrie à porter elle a gagné une première
manche ses petits enfants ont été
rapatriés c'est un bonheur mais un
bonheur amer parce qu'on sait qu'on a pu
notre fille et puis c'est un nouveau
départ pour les dix la bataille est loin
d'être terminée
les petits sont hospitalisés ils seront
soumis à une batterie de tests physiques
et psychologiques ou cours des
prochaines semaines
ils seront probablement confiée aux
services sociaux de l'état
ce que je souhaite c'est que ces enfants
reviennent qu'on en ait la garde qu'ils
puissent venir vivre ici dans cette
maison où a vécu leur mère qu'on puisse
leur apporter tout l'amour qu'on n'a pas
pu encore leur apporter parce que on les
a jamais la route vers leur réadaptation
à une vie plus calme sans parents mais
sans bombardements sera certainement
encore plus longue
[Musique]